aufgepasst meine klassen deutschen
freunde hier kommt alles was ihr zu
selbstbräuner wissen müssen
[Musik]
freunde der sonne hier ist eine traurige
zeit für alle freunde der sonne vor
allem für alle die ihre schöne
sommerbräune so langsam verlieren selbst
freunde relationen versprechen bräune
auch ohne sonne aber wie funktionieren
die sind überhaupt gut für uns und das
ist da gerade der neueste schritt auf
dem markt zunächst mal selbstbräuner
bräune ist nicht dasselbe wie
sonnenbrillen in der zeit in der sonne
oder unter uv-licht verbringen während
in unserer haut pigmente namens melamine
produziert ja männer hatten wir schon
einmal und zwar in diesem video hier da
ging es um hafer selbstbräuner passiert
allerdings etwas anderes in den meisten
selbst freuen ist ein molekül namens die
proxia der tourbus der a enthalten
anders als die sonne reagiert der nicht
mit den lebenden hautzellen soll nun mit
der äußersten hautschicht die aus dem
toten hautzellen besteht genannt strahlt
und corny genaugenommen reagieren die dh
selbstbräuner moleküle mit aminosäuren
aus unseren toten hautzellen und ihr
werdet nicht glauben was für eine
reaktion das genau ist team bei jahr
reaktion wäre meine emotionen gar nicht
genau nachvollziehen kann wäre unsere
videos zum backen und zum grillen für
kannst diesmal reaktions einen meiner
lieblings reaktion weise beim backen und
kochen für all die leckeren aromastoffe
und für all die wunderbaren braunen
farben sorgt also noch mal ob du
plätzchen frauen wachs oder bacon braun
frittiert oder selbstbräuner benutzt es
ist es dasselbe chemische prinzip heißt
es jetzt ich packe meine haut ist
selbstbräuner überhaupt gut die reaktion
zwischen dh an unseren toten hautzellen
ist völlig unbedenklich und verläuft
auch bei raumtemperatur bzw
haut temperatur und bei den
konzentrationen in denen dh in den
aktionen eingesetzt wird das sind so um
die fünf konnte man bisher auch keine
schädlichen folgen beobachten gab es
zwar eine studie die herausgefunden hat
dass dh nicht
von mexikanischen aktionen vertrag
erhält ihr habt mexikanischen 800d kommt
ihr auf die idee selbst freunde auf
mexikanischen aktion wird zu tun
jedenfalls wenn ihr zuhause einen
mexikanischen nackt und habt dann
schmiert er nicht mit selbstbräuner 1 1
sollte man allerdings bedenken die
moleküle die uns die fei träume
verschaffen heißen melanie dient die
sind übrigens auf den kaffee drin
jedenfalls sind sie nicht dasselbe wie
die mail an ihnen unsere haut pigmente
die melamine die im lebenden teil
unserer haut entstehen schützen uns zum
beispiel auch vor weiterer uv-strahlung
die melodien vom selbstbräuner
allerdings kaum noch schlimmer 24
stunden nach dem auftragen von
selbstbräunern ist die haut sogar noch
empfindlicher gegenüber uv licht als
sonst deswegen sollte man selbstbräuner
immer in kombi mit sonnenmilch verwenden
da selbstbräuner bräune aber nur auf der
färbung der äußersten toten hautschicht
beruht hält diese träume auch nur so ein
bis zwei wochen weil sich unsere haut
ständig erneuert in boston arbeiten die
wissenschaftler aber jetzt gerade an
einer neuen selbstbräuner revolution wo
die haut auch ohne sonne zur produktion
von echten melanin angeregt werden soll
das gäbe nicht nur nachhaltigere bräune
sondern auch ein extraschutz drücken wir
den wissenschaftlern die daumen schön
schlau was ist mit euch wer von euch
benutzen selbstbräuner oder habt ihr das
nicht nötig oder steht er auf
eine aristokratische plätze sind bereits
in die kommentare zusammen mit euren
fragen wie sie uns nächste woche bis
sein